switching gears Canada's Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau is asking for forgiveness
in the middle of his re-election
campaign after a photo of him wearing
brown face was made public the picture
published in a Time magazine article
online appears in a 2001 yearbook from a
private school where Trudeau used to
teach
he says the costume was from a party
with an Arabian Nights theme our
national correspondent Jericka Duncan is
with us Jericka how are Canadians
responding to the photo well they're not
happy for starters Trudeau has built his
political reputation on the promotion of
freedom and diversity in Canada so for
many this offensive photo of one of the
world's most powerful leaders likely
comes as a surprise and a disappointment
this was something that was unacceptable
and yes Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
said he is deeply sorry for a photo
showing him covered in dark makeup he
said it was part of an Aladdin costume
for a party nearly 20 years ago I take
responsibility for my decision to do
that I shouldn't have done it I should
have known better
Trudeau also admitted he wore brown face
as a high school student this additional
photo appears to confirm his story that
he used dark makeup to imitate singer
Harry Belafonte at a talent show it's
making a mockery of someone for what
they live and what the relived
experiences are I think he needs an
answer for it New Democratic Party
leader jag meet Singh called the 2001
image troubling and insulting and with
Canada's federal election just over a
month away the fallout could cast a
shadow over Trudeau's campaign why
didn't he tell people something about it
that question comes after US politicians
have been called out as racist for
wearing dark makeup in the past I don't
have an excuse for what I did
Virginia Governor Ralph Northam was
accused of wearing blackface in this
photo from the 1980s he talked about the
controversy with Gayle King in February
the man you're looking at and talking to
right now is not who I was as a leader
on the international stage Trudeau says
his focus now is moving forward I think
what is important is that yes people get
challenged on mistakes
made in the past that they recognize
those mistakes and they pledge to do
better that's what we expect two people
in a statement Conservative Party an
official opposition leader Andrew
Shearer said Trudeau is not fit to
govern when asked by reporters if he
would resign from office Trudeau did not
offer a direct response I think that it
would be interesting you know what
you've done
you know what pictures you've taken if
people would come out ahead of this
stuff yeah you had almost 20 years to
say you know what let me just talk about
this now I did this we'll find it and
then come on Rob yep I hope other people
are listening to you thinking you know
jury cos right maybe I have had
something to say maybe I should look at
my yes yes thank you Jericho